THE NEWS GETS MADE.
TODAY WE HAVE A SPECIAL PROGRAM
FOR YOU.
AS PRESIDENT TRUMP'S WAR WITH
THE MEDIA GETS EVEN MORE
PERSONAL.
THE PRESIDENT IS GRAPPLING WITH
SENATE REPUBLICANS WHO MISSED A
SELF-IMPOSED DEADLINE ON HEALTH
CARE.
HE'S PREPARING FOR A STAREDOWN
THIS WEEK WITH RUSSIAN PRESIDENT
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
BUT ON TWITTER HE'S WRESTLING
WITH -- US.
LOOK AT THIS VIDEO FROM HIS
TWITTER ACCOUNT THIS MORNING.
THIS IS A WWE WRESTLE MANIA
VIDEO FROM YEARS AGO WHEN TRUMP
USED TO SHOW UP AT WWE EVENTS.
YOU CAN SEE THAT THE CNN LOGO
HAS BEEN SUPERIMPOSED ONTO THE
OTHER FIGHTER'S FACE.
THIS SHOWED UP ON A REDDIT
MESSAGE BOARD DAYS AGO.
NOW IT'S SHOWING UP ON THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES'
OWN TWITTER FEED.
THE EARLY REACTION IN THE LAST
90 MINUTES HAVE RANGED FROM THIS
IS JUVENILE, RIDICULOUS,
IDIOTIC, OR WAIT NO IT'S JUST
FUNNY.
HE'S JUST HAVING FUN.
WAIT, NO IT'S ACTUALLY SCARY,
DANGEROUS.
WE'VE HEARD A WIDE RANGE OF
REACTIONS TO THIS.
AND WE HAVE A PANEL STANDING BY.
BUT FIRST CNN'S RESPONSE.
THE STRONGEST STATEMENT I'VE
SEEN FROM CNN OR ANY NEWS OUTLET
THIS YEAR IN RESPONSE TO THE
PRESIDENT'S ATTACKS.
QUOTE IT IS A SAD DAY WHEN THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
ENCOURAGES VIOLENCE AGAINST
REPORTERS.
CLEARY SARAH HUCKABEE SANDERS
LIED WHEN SHE SAID THE PRESIDENT
HAD NEVER DONE SO.
INSTEAD OF PREPARING FOR HIS
OVERSEAS TRIP, HIS FIRST MEETING
WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN, NORTH KOREA
AND WORKING ON THE HEALTH CARE
BILL HE IS INVOLVED IN JUVENILE
BEHAVIOR FAR BELOW THE DIGNITY
OF HIS